it takes a lot to
recalibrate um what your dreams are what
your hopes are uh what you want for your
kids you know all that stuff how to
shift gears now to being a single parent
and yeah and it and it's can we stay
close in proximity and all that I want
to be around them I want to see them I
want to be a dad yeah and we have 50/50
custody you know and and so anyway
there's just a lot of a lot of stuff but
so how was very frustrating and my dad
was great my dad was amazing you know
that's thing you know you you take your
parents for granted so easily because
you think they don't know and we also
think this is a generation again we're
talking about these old school walk it
off what would he know
about
heartache you know what a stupid thing
to think the honey do with Ryan
[Music]
sichler